most of the suit is 2.2 million people
live in rural areas like this one in
Taba possio in the village of met along
hamas Akali there's electricity but
despite living alongside the met along
dam they don't have running water
mimosa was selamat she lives here with
her five children and ten grandchildren
their existence is hand-to-mouth
surviving only on her monthly government
pension of $50 no one in her family has
a job he forgot feeding these kids is a
constant battle there are days where I
have nothing and we go without eating
anything sometimes I have to ask my
neighbors for help sometimes they can
help with one meal other times we go to
bed with no food government statistics
show that almost a quarter of working
age people most of them young don't have
jobs while the government has
implemented reforms to tackle
unemployment
progress is slow experts say political
instability is making matters worse I
have been here for two years and I have
seen very interesting developments
worrying developments in terms of
instability as you know the Prime
Minister has announced that he intends
to retire not later than July this year
but also we have seen four government
reshuffle in about two and a half years
and of course this is very destabilizing
for the administration the suit too has
had a series of military coos and
political battles over the last decade
Prime Minister Tom Tobin is under
pressure to resign while he says he'll
retire within five months his leadership
has created political tensions
especially as police want to charge him
with the 2017 murder of his estranged
and second wife dipole ello his third
wife Marcia has already been charged
with the crime members of the governing
Alba Souter convention party want him
gone and I in discussions to name a
successor but the party's divided
opposition parties are also calling for
tabari to go the eight-year-olds
leadership was again criticized as
Parliament prepared to present the
latest
national budget the World Bank says that
while poverty in Lesotho has fallen over
the last 15 years it's still widespread
and affects nearly half the population
many are concerned that the political
instability will only worsen the
challenges the government's facing many
people in Lesotho just want their lives
to improve but with political infighting
looking far from over
they may have a long wait for me
Ramallah al Jazeera Maseru Lesotho